to the lobby i am your host Chris waters
filling in for Danny O'Dwyer who's on
vacation in his homeland now before I
introduce the gentleman sitting next to
me I'll tell you a little bit about the
show today we've got some great games
that are finding their way to new
platforms rogue legacy and the swapper
and we're also going to talk about our
contest to give away PlayStation fours
plural but all that's going to come a
little later and first I wanted to talk
about some big news that hip gamespot
here last week as many of you already
may know many people who helped define
gamespot as a site are no longer with us
and I want to help you I want you to
help me join them in giving them a
proper farewell we're going to miss the
editorial acumen of Carolyn Pettit Tom
mcshay and Maxwell McGee as well as the
production wizardry of Wernher von Goff
Benito Gonzalez and Jan hair Justin
Calvert's leadership helped define the
editorial vision of the site for over a
decade and Sharon Gosselin right from
the very beginning helped make everyone
here look good with her awesome copy
editing and of course as ryan mcdonald a
man whose growth as a leader in
production ace mirrored the growth of
GameSpot itself I know I speak for
everyone here when I say we're going to
miss these folks and we can't wait to
see what new adventures they get up to I
can't wait to see what new adventures we
get up to as well because as any of you
who have followed the site for a while
no changes a constant around here from
new shows and new editorial features to
evolving news coverage and a whole site
redesign with your feedback and with the
passionate people who work here we're
going to really try to continue to make
gamespot a place where people who are
passionate about games love to come and
love to talk about games and speaking of
some of those guys two dudes who are
passionate about games Brad shoemaker
and Sean McGuinness hi guys i am yeah
yeah well i mean you it's settled on me
okay that's why your bio that's why you
wanted me here okay right I have a
passion for your ability to memorize
extended monologue that was pretty good
right yeah I had that I jotted it down
you don't want to make sure I didn't
make any boner jokes yeah cuz I don't
want to take away Danny's thing right
it's a good show that's a that's a no
Dwyer signature you don't want to steal
this boner thunder all right ah speaking
of games with boner jokes and then rogue
legacy rogue legacy does it have boner
jokes and Scott oh right yeah
it might or is it just more irreverent
humor I don't know anyways this is a
game that's been out for a little while
on pc but now you are playing at sean on
the playstation 4 this is actually one
of the ps4 ps3 PS vita cross platform
games and ross save which is one my
favorite things about it so I've been
able to play on my Vita while traveling
and play it on my ps4 at home it's uh
it's the first game where I've really
gotten into the whole cross a function
of it's the first game I can think of
that's done cross save right oh yeah
like yeah most of the games that ever
cross they have enabled you have to dig
through options menus and like find a
sinc function or whatever like if you
play this game on a new platform it
immediately says hey like the save data
is not as new as the one in the cloud
you want to play the one in the cloud
you say yes and like you're off the
races please it's super streamlined yeah
it's super painless too so i am going to
i think there's a little hidden i'm a
little secret there buddy you are you
wearn oh yeah hidden chest nicely done
yeah i'm not sure if we cut to it in
time but basically when you see these
little dark gray spots in the ground
that means it's a little hidden area and
then it's go to their here and start
whacking stuff that chest was invisible
a second ago so that you unlock to ruin
their and rogue legacy is a road like in
the sense that it you know every run you
start from scratch but that's not quite
accurate the cross save you know matters
because you build this castle yeah yeah
it's a huge progression games roguelike
with persistence which is kind of an
oxymoron yeah but roguelike like I mean
pick the color of rogue light right is
that I know how thuy you want to get
with your with your terminology 50
little names for things yeah so I beat
the game already and I'm on new game+
right now which means which means that
I'm going through the castle a second
time means all the enemies are different
colors you're gay they're like much much
tougher enemies you can tell I'm
actually level 180 right now so I've
played a pretty good amount of rogue
legacy I [ __ ] yeah not bad is this red
sword one of those vampire swords what
takes the help from the enemies no but I
do have some some runes that allow me to
do that i'm at the point where i
actually get like four HP and for MP for
every kill which is
that's pretty crucial for like
survivability in this yeah yeah if you
guys have any questions about rogue
legacy go ahead and tweet them to add
gamespot com put them in the chat on the
site and will relay them here I I bet a
lot of you guys out there have played
this game a bunch as have I I only got
to beat the first boss though so I don't
know if that classifies as a bunch so
win it ok big eyeball do is this your
first time I'm game no I played on pc
eee wit and I beat the eyeball boss ok
but that's that's where it starts and
ends for you yeah yeah What About You
bread I beat the second boss I think on
the pc I'm just gonna put it down for
one reason or another but all in on the
ps4 version though yes for version are
you not happy too man oh I've got on the
Vita I've just mostly been playing at
home for whatever reason but uh you know
if God forbid I haven't finish this game
by the time packs rolls around this will
definitely be an airplane game for me
that is just a few that's like what
three weeks away for ya it's not far but
you guys have a big packs thing planned
yes that's really stuff is coming
whether yeah excellent whoa we'll get
you too driba jabber about that a little
bit more uh I don't know maybe in a
closer to pack straight yeah yeah once
we know what we're doing mm-hmm which
would maybe which was maybe gonna be
like 45 minutes before it all goes down
yes sixth emilio goes yeah that's how it
goes for us anything last last year we
were up to like an hour and a half so
nice getting their progress alright so
Sean like the when you're actually
playing the game you start off without
the ability to like double jump or dash
but pretty quickly you get like your
core set of abilities and then it's
there's there's not a lot of them though
it's not like you can use all sorts of
different moves here it's like writing
sword jump maybe dash thank you some
magic I'm gonna go ahead and sacrifice
myself so that we can check out like the
character selection stuff cuz that's
kind of if you guys haven't played
roulette legacy that's so much the crux
of what makes the game interesting no
you thought you were done oh yeah so
there you go that's actually 11 ability
that I've unlocked in the game so I've
been slain so rogue legacy yeah give you
give it to me what that's all about and
family Chris family died and you get to
select which one of your children you
get to play which one of your chosen
progeny will leader
now unlike most families you actually
can reroll your children if you [ __ ] the
ability to reroll your jewelry roll your
children yo Shawn that fiscally it's not
exactly legal no that's just getting a
divorce and starting a new family with
other kids that you love more yes so I
I've got two favorite classes right
there you can you start with I think
what is it like three basic classes and
then go yeah and then you unlock of much
more specialized ones as the game goes
on my favorites well this Plunkett is
good for that's really weak but you
collect a lot of gold mmm a hero for
orders but this one is fun to the how do
you pronounce it okay okay okay hokage
yeah I was gonna say oh gosh come on
stop French just ain't no rudo that's
not as shoemaker knows okay gay is also
known as OnPoint I'll talk about that
all right what good so and then this is
a if you've never played roblox see this
is also a feature that makes it very
different from other roguelikes because
there is all this persistence so I can
upgrade like my maximum equipment weight
or my armor or this is where like you
unlock new like that death defy when I
came back from the death before yeah
that's because every time I die I have a
three percent chance of coming back so
basically you got really lucky you got
really then sacrificed that chance so
that you know yeah yeah so I'm going to
upgrade this make it a four four point
five percent chance and then I'm gonna
put a little bit of this this is good so
it's okay I'll 2900 to improve my health
and I have 2981 right now so as the the
occasionally frustrating thing is that
you sacrifice most or all of your gold
when you get back in the castle yeah so
you got you got to spend all the way
down if you can because you're just
going to throw away whatever you don't
spend all right so this is my setup that
I've got that the dragon sword is what
you were asking about earlier basically
this is just a super high damage sword
that's really really [ __ ] heavy it's
a pretty boss sword yes well it takes up
a lot of way and it weight is just how
much you can carry yeah right exactly
but if I wanted to do like full
vampirism I've got like the bloodsword
and like the blood helm and all that
stuff so I mean you I'd you just vampire
yourself up and then we'll send bratton
as the vampire you maker
I could go super vampire and then
there's also the runes which allow me to
like get like four different double
jumps if I wanted to do that it seems
excessive so you can spec yourself into
some really really never has enough
double JavaScript daughters come on is
that not it's for jump double jumps just
for jumps or is it eight jumps it's just
it's just for chow I don't know man 14
jumped you're asking questions we're not
equipped to answer yeah and then so like
Brad said any leftover money that you
have you have to give to this guy to pay
your toll to get through the castle
again that dudes name is death right and
one of the upgrades is all Sharon you
can share you can reduce the number of
cash so I only give him ninety percent
of my cash yeah as long as those nine
goals that's going to help you out big
time and it's not the castle hampson
like the there you'd see on that map
therefore there are four areas areas are
always you know gonna be the same kind
of like enemy variety and tile set but
the map is different every time yes
exactly so this first room is very
different from how it was last time well
unless you there's that guy out front
you can pay right yeah like get the same
one you Jin architect yeah you can walk
through the previous layout if you want
although I never found a whole lot of
use for that I don't know that you guys
that is super helpful when you are
committed to beating a boss okay does it
always want to warp to where the boss is
it does it resumes that you killed when
you do that or they all dead no I think
it I think the enemies are all bad oh
yeah that was fast that was fast is this
is this just single new game plus it's
not because I think there's a new game +
+ right is there this is Los so this is
your second run right this is my second
run this is frickin brutal yes it that
way worse than is Brad yes want to get
your hands on it I didn't give a shot
I'll give a [ __ ] throw some trust me to
manhandle you a file on if you want to
reroll your children just hit the
touchpad Oh what do we got here what is
glaucoma it's just it's dark this is the
other thing like the traits very random
traits that like doing it you can yeah
you can have glaucoma and so you can't
see as far or like you're near-sighted
or farsighted yeah and some of them are
totally inconsequential like you're gay
a or your ball or you fart random are ya
you randomly fire you swear when you get
hit yeah or the castle looks like Tron
and then there's the one that just turns
it all upside down oh now never pick
that one which is unjust able you need
to kill that bloodline that can that
gene cannot be allowed to reproduce are
you gonna do five double jumps not do
you seriously not have a dash I have a
dash no actually I don't was that I
haven't gone through I've gone through
the whole game without the dash is that
your only only have the one double down
I've got a few double Jerry man I got to
get kitted out here oh you can do the
double jump if you go to the blacksmith
there's a double jump cape oh really
yeah so go to the brown oh no it's not
the double jump it's the dash that I
wants out oh you want that I'll hold on
how you don't play with that but I got
to figure out what's rune I can get rid
of four then how about let's see oh Sean
meanwhile Sean kits it out groups you
ride in the twitch chat wants to know is
there an end final boss there is yeah I
mean there's for initial bosses and then
there is a final boss and but once you
beat him that's what triggers new game+
and you can just replay the game a whole
bunch of times okay so this is my second
playthrough and I can already tell that
I'm going to replay the game a full
second time and is it I mean what is it
just because the action is still so like
it gets tougher and it's really fun yeah
it scales up really well there's still a
whole bunch of unlocks and gear and
stuff that I haven't even got yet you
know like when I beat the game for the
first time I had only unlocked like
maybe less than half of the equipment so
there's still like a pretty massive
progression there's still miles to go
for the intrepid adventurer Sean
mcginnis and his bloodline remember or
don't forget since you've got the
Barbarian you can hit triangle for the
dragon shout this road ah that was
actually a question we had from yellow
sanchez was can you unlock different
shouts or is it maybe system show just
the one shout for this particular class
but you can get different magics oh yeah
was it the magics your billing cycle Oh
couldn't find the dash I so much health
I don't know what the room that was on
but you like them yeah without a dash
whilst in the darkness here without a
dash I feel like it's a tool it's a
maneuverability yeah I'm a much bigger
fan of drills more jumps and the the
health and magic drains good because
especially when you're playing as the
barbarian which is essentially the tank
you can go on some epic epic runs if you
are draining health with every kill you
mean containing it from enemies you
resupply your endless blood lot exactly
i mean the best gold runs that I've ever
had in this game are as the barbarian
draining health not as the spelunk yet
the sort of minor class that gets more
gold / pounds plunkett is capable
definitely of getting more but I just
find with my particular play style which
is a little bit more aggressive haha
spelunker or the splunk yet you have to
play really defensively and you're just
an aggro kind of guy i put a grown kind
of guy listen I just need to pop off in
there and it's got a puff oh yeah those
those guys shoot the bullets in every
direction Brad what about you man what's
your what's your uh who's your jam I
don't know that I've settled on a
favorite I'm still in the early phase of
the game where I'm just quite grinding
out upgrades so I play a lot of the
minor or is the kind of yeah first form
of this bunker but that's just to get
gold cuz i got sucks um yeah i mean you
know the obviously the barbarians the
kind of like you said the one that's
gonna be the most survivable I noticed
that you guys haven't like this is
what's the problem I felt I ran into was
like forgetting to use magic or trying
to be too cute with it and like save my
magic yeah when really I could have just
used it and survived a little longer so
the the Lich Kings I think it's lich
king right is that the class that's one
of the classes he arched made mark this
is the second form of the Lich yeah you
basically you gain max health every time
you kill and then your special ability
is you can turn your health into more
mana yeah you just flip the bar yeah
right so you'd have 400 men right
you just kill more guys and you and you
get that health back up so like that's
whoa that's a good class to maximize
your magic usage with and that one's
cool because it actually increases your
maximum HP with every kill so you start
it like 120 HP or whatever and it
actually the bar actually increases
whereas with the barbarian it starts
high and then so so far this has been
like we've discussed a bunch of sort of
different of the strategical elements in
the game you know different stats to
keep in mind different strategies do you
find that it's like when you first start
playing is it in is it overwhelming at
all is it like i don't i don't
understand how all this works so it's
not so much like grasping the concepts
but like there are so many uh parades
when you first start yeah cuz every time
you buy an upgrade you unlock like three
more and something i didn't notice the
first time i played it is that each time
you buy an upgrade all the other upper
80 a more expensive yeah yeah so you
kind of need it you need to pick and
choose early on what you put your money
in so yeah because everything else gonna
get harder to get afterwards that's what
makes it hard to just kind of like brute
force your way through the game is like
upgrades strategy becomes very important
your build is if you spread yourself too
thin you can make the game really tough
on yourself in terms of upgrades like a
final boss gonna go to amiga fight about
you want it you're gonna already beat
this boss actually it was this guy even
so you can do like these it's not like a
crazy I Lahore yeah the crazy high level
version yes please they must have to see
it i think my path is clear yeah neo
here here fighting this guy inside iran
yours your truck here's your tron what
happened to my dude why is really his
health is going down with each hit
there's no way which which person are
you now know your character changed into
central also change class you have way
less health yes no they're all different
what just what man is it oh we're right
so that's one of the special bosses like
you actually can come back after that
yeah can you just keep doing that yeah
you can but it's i've tried doing it
like 10 times in a row and i made
basically zero progress is it the same
character that you like first beat the
boss with maybe um
no actually that's one of the games it's
it's not a game that's huge on secrets
and the way that spelunky is uh huh but
that's definitely one thing I would
classifies one of the games secrets what
is another thing you would class what as
one of the game secrets what it's like
to feel emotions sure I mean that's you
know that's the secret of life yeah
itself that's what rogue legacy is a
microcosm of yet see now you just like
you took hell of hits from that thing oh
yeah and you're my super tank top first
also I'm like so in my new game plus
I've beat the first two bosses which
means that I'm pretty high level for
this area we saw Brad go up to the area
directly above which is the Maya oh yeah
yeah yeahs heaped his head in there and
then was having none of it oh the
sequences you maybe go all the way to
the right and fine or all the way down
and before give us a glimpse of another
realm Brad you want to see hell I'll
just the dungeons yeah no not hell oh
it's not hell Wow the sequence in
difficulty is this area of the castle
yep to the right is the forest and then
up is the Maya and then down is dungeon
take us to the forest Bradley right
starting to look dicey you got you still
got 325 health and you're getting health
with every kill so better not die oh
here you go you're at the forest now Hey
look oh yeah what is happening god oh my
gosh wow this is the forest this is a
different situation this is one of the
areas where when there's a lot of joking
oh hey these guys welcome to rogue
legacy new game on us that's a real kick
in the junk I was like a bullet hell
level oh yeah yes well that's that's
where the the fuss Road dog comes in
super handy cuz it clears out all the
projectiles yeah and is that just on a
cool down or does that take it uses mana
yeah you say man I say mana let's call
the whole thing off a pistol shrimp
paste of shrimp way better than the
defaults on pumping that pistol shrimp
you guys know what a pistol shrimp is
pistol shrimp yeah a rap name look like
this in addition to a brad shoemakers
rap name it's a shrimp that like can
shoot a part of its body so fast that
the water jet it creates just like burns
up I've heard of that burns up its it's
like right it's like tits n some
insanely high degree of heat right yeah
hatred I just one of us point out I
don't know if there's any pistol shrimp
in this come on help what do you point
out my help Brad's on a good run he's
got 10,000 gold oh is that a second I is
that gonna buy the house nice gold crabs
is that gonna do you well oh yeah you
can buy what if you upgrade to that and
so why are you going after the bad guy
Brad as I don't know as you want that
gold cuz I'm your gold that gold an
idiot yeah greed Brad go get mine the
unmaking of all men or get sean's I
guess Shawn's okay I appreciate it
you're all right that's that's rogue
legacy uh net it's out been out on pc
for a while now out on ps4 ps3 PS vita
cross by for a leg what 15 15 bucks in
17 bucks i'm very very good purchase one
locus I just give it a teen 99 guys
giving it the thumbs in such a good vita
game because it's great for just like
iron I'm gonna play one quick session
I'm just one quick session which
inevitably turns into like eight but
still it's and then you've been standing
in your living room like not sitting on
a couch because you like came in the
door you know I just got to finish this
up yeah and then you sell your backpack
on like five minutes later yep weird
stuff rogue legacy uh Brad shoemaker
thanks for coming up sharing your
expertise Sean McGinnis nicely done
thank you
you